GILL WARD: Hello.
Welcome, everybody, to
this afternoon's session.
Thanks for coming.
We're here to talk about driving
product excellence, based
on feedback from
users like yourselves.
So my name is Gill Ward.
I'm a User Experience
Research lead--
in G speech-- and a
quantitative UX researcher.
LINDSAY MOORE:
I'm Lindsay Moore.
I'm a Qualitative User
Experience researcher
for Google Drive.
JOSEPH BEARS: I'm Joe Bears.
I'm the Vice President
and Chief Information
Officer of Hingham
Institution for Savings.
BEN DRURY: And I'm Ben Drury.
I'm a Qualitative User
Experience researcher,
focused on the Hangouts
video meeting experience.
So we're going to
talk to you today
about how we incorporate
user feedback,
and to develop products that
we think will work really
well for our users.
We think it's
especially important
to keep our users'
needs in mind when
we're developing products for
productivity and collaboration.
So late last year, the
UX director for G Suite,
Lucas Pettinati, published
an article in "Fast Company"
titled "How to test
products like a Googler."
In this-- now it's changing.
OK.
In this article he
made the argument
that you should be
collecting feedback,
not just to make sure what
you're already working on
is the right thing
to be working on
and to confirm your direction.
Instead, you should
be getting feedback
in order to figure out new
things you should be working
on, to uncover new user
needs, and to push your team
in new and creative directions.
So we want to talk a little bit
about how we do this at Google.
So we're going to
start by sharing
a little bit of an inside
look at how we focus on user
journeys, rather than features.
And then we're going to talk
you through the whole product
feedback cycle--
from uncovering user
needs early on, collecting
early feedback, all the
way through till launch,
when we continue
to collect feedback
via metrics and analytics.
We're then going to do a deep
dive into how Team Drive ran
a user feedback program to
get their product to the state
that it's in today.
So we believe that
in order to build
robust, excellent
products, you really
need to ensure that
you're building
products that are going
to meet your users' needs.
So we always have
the end user in mind.
Before we even start
building something,
we're talking to users to find
out what problems they have
and how we can help
solve those problems.
We want to know how they're
trying to get their work done.
We want the products to
be useful, easy to use,
and always reliable.
So we've moved
away from thinking
about individual
features and instead we
think about the broader goals
that our users have in mind.
I'm going to give you kind
of a silly example of this.
So how many of you
have heard of H-Day.
Nobody?
OK.
So H-Day was a day in
1967 when Sweden switched
from driving on the
left side of the road
to driving on the right side of
the road, all overnight, which
sounds kind of crazy.
But I want you to
imagine that you're
living outside of
Stockholm at this time,
just before H-Day happens.
And you have one goal
in mind every morning,
and that is to get
to work on time.
So you drive into work and
it's pretty straightforward.
Every day, you follow the same
roads, you make the same turns,
maybe you're spending more time
admiring the beautiful city
around you than actually
thinking about how all
these connections go together.
But eventually you end
up at this one-way road,
you turn down it, and,
great, you're at work.
You've made it there on time.
You've accomplished your goal.
Now H-Day arrives and
everything is switched.
So you're going to be going to
work for the first time driving
on the other side of the road.
And you're pretty worried about
how this is going to work.
You leave a little bit
earlier than usual.
Maybe you're driving a
little bit slower than usual.
You might be driving more
carefully than usual.
But, overall, you're
finding that it's actually
working pretty well.
You're on the other
side of the road,
but you're still making
good time to work.
Until you hit that one-way
road close to your work
and instead of driving down it,
you see a do not enter sign,
because the one-way
road is flipped
in the opposite direction.
So why am I talking about this?
It represents
exactly why we need
to focus on journeys
instead of features.
Because when we look at
each individual component
of this journey, they
all work the same way
they always did before.
So a two-way road
still allows traffic
to go in two directions.
Signs mean the same thing
that they've always meant.
And your car fundamentally
works the same way
that it always worked.
The problem is when you connect
all these pieces together,
you can no longer
accomplish your goal
of getting to work on
time, because of that one
little tweak at the end.
So we look at the
overall picture--
the journey-- and the
user fails at their goal.
So I want to take this back
to software development.
So we know that our
users don't think
about individual features.
They just think about what
they want to get done at work,
and how they can
be most productive.
So imagine that you just
want to send a video to one
of your colleagues.
Your goal is to get this
video to your colleague.
This sounds simple
enough, but it actually
used to be kind of challenging
in Gmail because of the size
limits on files that you
could attach to an e-mail.
We've improved this greatly.
And today, when you attach
a large file to an e-mail,
instead of not sending, you are
prompted to upload it to Drive,
and then prompted to share
it with your colleagues.
This might not be the journey
that you're expecting to take.
But you're able to
achieve your goal.
And it's very easy
for you to do that.
So we've allowed people to
get their work done quickly.
So, for some of you, you
might be thinking, great,
but I don't need to send e-mails
with videos to my colleagues.
That's not like a fundamental
goal of what I do.
And we understand that.
And that's another really
important point here
is that people in different
roles have different goals,
and they need to
accomplish different tasks.
Take, for example, your
sales representatives.
They spend a lot of
time on the phone.
Fundamentally, they're all
about setting meetings, getting
feedback from their
customers, and keeping
track of all of those things--
maybe on a spreadsheet.
Your developers,
on the other hand--
they're spending time
heads down, writing code,
trying to build that
next great app that
can scale in response
to increased traffic.
Their goal is just to get that
app out the door and make sure
that it's always up and running.
And then, finally, your G
Suite admin, which is probably
some of you in this room.
You're the buffer between
your end users and Google.
You're there to roll
out new products,
help people learn how
to use those products.
You might jump on
video to help them
troubleshoot a new product.
And you might jump
into the [? C ?] panel,
to understand who's
adopting the product
and where you need to
help people more to start
using the product.
So the question
now is, how do we
make sure that we get all
of these voices involved
as we're getting feedback
from our customers?
And I'm going to hand it
over to Gill now for that.
GILL WARD: Great.
Thanks, Ben.
OK.
So let's get into the
heart of this talk--
how we gather user
feedback, and then
how we leverage that to make
an impact in our products.
But before we do that, I want to
get a sense of your experience
with user research, and with
providing feedback to Google.
So have you ever--
please raise your hand--
submitted feedback in
product, or through surveys
and products?
Great.
That's awesome to see.
How about participated
in a usability test?
Wow.
That's a lot more
than I was expecting.
Awesome.
Have you been observed by a
researcher in your workplace?
Even a few of those, too.
That's great.
So we've had a lot of different
exposure to UX research.
And we're going to
talk a little bit more
about all these
different methods
and how we leverage
them within Google.
We're going to break this down
into four different stages--
from an early stage of
discovery and testing
through trusted
tester, early adopter,
and general availability.
And throughout all of
the examples that we're
talking about, we're
going to try and point out
exactly what impact our research
has had on those products.
Because it's really important to
us that whatever research we do
does have an impact.
We know that your
time is valuable.
And we want to make sure
that we can leverage that.
Saying that, I'm not going
to be able to provide
pinpointed evidence of all
the impact that we've had,
because some of this research
has just been too recent.
And, obviously, we can't
talk about product direction.
So bear with me there.
OK.
So let's dive into
the earliest stage.
At this point, we're
defining new products.
We're fleshing out
the feature set.
We're pinning down the
details of those products.
There are two main
types of research
that we do at this point.
I'll give you an example of
a discovery type, an example
of a testing type of research.
But, before that, who has
heard of eat your own dog food?
OK.
So quite a lot of people.
So the premise behind
this is, before we
give our products to users, we
should be using them ourselves,
right?
And, luckily, we have
a lot of Googlers
who really care
about our products.
And so they will
take time working
with really early-stage
products that are
really rough around the edges.
They probably have
lots of bugs in them.
They might not be
quite usable just yet.
But they will give us really
opinionated and critical
feedback.
They do not hold back.
And that helps us move
that product forward.
It helps us iron out
those rough edges.
And it helps us fix a
lot of those early bugs.
But we know that Googlers
aren't like our G Suite users.
Right?
In many ways-- one example--
if a Googler is trying to create
a document or a spreadsheet
or a presentation, typically,
we use our G Suite editors
to do that.
And we know that, for
a lot of our customers,
on the other hand, Microsoft
is still part and parcel
of their work day.
So if we just
focused on Googlers,
we wouldn't understand how
our products interfaced
with Microsoft products.
So that's one example
where we really
need to get outside of Google.
So we do.
We want to, figuratively, peer
in to different workplaces,
to understand what's
happening in our users' lives.
And there were three reasons
why we want to do this.
We want to understand
their user journeys.
We want to understand what
they're trying to achieve,
what tools they're using--
whether it's our
tools or other tools--
what tools they are
using to do that.
The flip side of
that is, of course,
what's holding them back?
What are the obstacles?
What are the
opportunities that we have
to improve those user journeys?
And then, thirdly,
we can also get
some really great early
feedback about our new products.
If we're thinking-- if
we have a potential idea,
we can test it out
with our users.
Does it resonate with them?
OK.
So the first two of
these we're going
to use this first method,
the discovery type method.
And that's going to
give us a lot of insight
into those first two types.
So this discovery,
this exploratory phase,
we're really trying to get
a holistic understanding.
We want to see how people
work in the workplace,
relative to their team,
relative to the organization
as a whole, when they're
working by themselves.
And this example-- this photo
is taken from an example
a few years ago.
We took a number of engineers,
product managers, designers,
as well as researchers,
into multiple companies
across the US, and
internationally, too.
And we gave them this guidebook.
And, you know, it kind of can
guide them through questions
that they can ask
people that they meet--
things to look out for.
And they have a
place to write down
notes, which we then
brought back into Google,
and we could share between us.
So there were two
really awesome outcomes.
The first of these was we got
our engineers, our product
team, talking with
our end users.
And that enables
those-- our engineers--
to really gain empathy and
understanding of our users.
It's one of the
most powerful tools
that we have as researchers.
The flip side of
that, of course,
is we have a ton of data.
So we trawled through
all of that data.
And there was so much
information in there--
bugs that needed to be
fixed; feature requests.
But then we also started
to see high level patterns.
And one of those
high level patterns
was that even three
or four years ago when
we did this study, mobile was
ubiquitous in the workplace.
And that brought us to
start focusing on mobile,
to ensure that we have parity
between our mobile and desktop
products.
And we're at the point now
where I can take my phone,
I can start a document;
I can leave comments
on somebody else's documents;
I can collaborate with my team
wherever I am.
So we really see
this long-term impact
from this kind of research.
So that's a discovery research.
On the opposite side,
we have testing.
So we do iterative research
on early-stage concepts,
or even later-stage
products, where we just
need to figure out the user
interaction with this product.
We need to iron out those edges.
And we have individuals
either come in to Google
or we interview them
over video chat as well.
And we get them to walk
through a scenario using
either the concept
or the product,
and get them to do that
representative task,
so that we can see how
they perform that task.
And, you know, there's a
number of different things
we can pull out of that.
We get a sense of, does the
concept resonate with them?
Is this a problem that our users
are actually trying to solve?
Does the current set-up--
is it usable?
Can people achieve that goal?
And then we also just get
to hear other concerns
and other feedback.
And so, from this, we
get really early feedback
that can help us hone the
direction of our product,
and give us
confidence that we are
heading in the right direction.
We run these studies
every week, across the US,
across the world.
And so, of course, that
means that we always
need more people to test with.
So if you would
like to join with us
and provide feedback
in that manner,
we would love to
have you sign up.
There's a couple more QR
codes at the back of the room
on the way out, too.
This research panel is
for G Suite end users.
We're looking for
companies who will sign up.
We can't promise
that everybody will
be able to join the
panel at this stage,
because it is a pilot.
But we're hoping to get
lots of people signing up,
so that we can continue to
do this early-stage research,
and allow you to have an impact
in our product direction.
And with that, I'm going to
hand it back over to Ben.
BEN DRURY: So I'm
going to tell you
a little bit about the
next couple of areas
where we get feedback.
These are trusted testers
and early adopter programs,
which are more
formal collaborations
with small groups of our users.
In both of these phases, we
work with a cross-section
of businesses--
different sizes,
different verticals--
to try and be as representative
of the kind of people
that we work with every
day as we possibly can.
We're really focused
on fit and finish,
rather than discovering
new product directions.
But you'll see there
are some times where
we make some interesting
tweaks to our products.
I'm going to use the new
Hangouts video meeting
experience as the example here.
When we kicked off
this project, we really
wanted to take a
fresh new look on how
we could build an
enterprise-focused video
meeting software that would
work well across web, mobile,
and in the in-room experience--
dedicated meeting rooms.
And we wanted to focus on
identifying those core pain
points that people experience
with the offerings today,
eliminate those, and make
a product that would really
make for effective meetings.
So we started with that
early discovery work
that Gill mentioned already.
And two really key parts
here were field visits
and interviews.
So with field visits we
were able to actually go out
to some of our
customers and observe
them using their existing
software to complete
video meetings.
We were able to see these
social interactions, and what
makes a meeting really
flow, and what's
important to making
a meeting productive.
We then did deep-dive
interviews with some
of the people who participated
in those meetings,
to understand how much
those problems come up--
like how frequently do they
encounter those problems?
And what are the
sort of common themes
that they see, in
terms of trying to make
their meetings more productive?
And we learned two really
interesting things here.
The first is that people
really care about big meetings.
They don't want to have to
worry about the number of people
they're inviting to the meeting.
They just want to
be able to have
as many people in that
meeting as possible.
The second is that
they really care
about people being able to
get into the meeting easily.
And this doesn't
just mean that we
should do a great job of getting
people into a video meeting.
It also means that
we have to open it up
to people who are dialing
in on their phones.
So to meet market needs,
we need to make it
so that if you have
somebody who's traveling
and doesn't have a
good Wi-Fi connection,
or you have a customer who
just doesn't like showing up
on video conferencing, they're
able to connect to your meeting
as well.
So these were two
things that we sort of
incorporated into our work
in building and designing
this new product.
I'm going to skip
over the phase where
we did some usability
testing and dog-fooding here,
and jump right into our
trusted tester program.
So trusted tester is
an invite-only program,
where UX, product, and sales
works really closely together
to identify a small
subset of our users
who are willing to
take the risk to work
with us with a product that's
not fully fleshed out yet.
We want people who are
responsive, constructively
critical, willing to give
lots of feedback, and also
willing to experiment
with us a little bit
as they try out these products.
We ask for a lot of
regular feedback.
And we're working very,
very closely with our admins
at this point.
But we think that there's
a mutually beneficial
relationship here,
because the admins also
get the chance to
see a new product,
and really be involved in
the roadmap for that product.
So we engage closely
with G Suite admins,
trying to build up
their confidence
that they can roll this product
out to all of their end users.
The goal is for
them to roll it out
to everybody in their company,
so that they can then bubble up
as much feedback as possible
from their end users
to say how well the
product is working
in supporting user needs.
So this gives us a
chance to kind of test
the product in the wild, and see
what user journeys people are
taking with it.
In this case, we also
did some observation.
So once they had rolled the
product out to their end users,
we went out and actually
watched them participating
in meetings with the new
Hangouts video meeting
experience, and then
conducted some surveys
to understand how it compared
to their past experiences.
And, again, we got some
interesting insights here.
Sitting in on those
meetings, we saw
that, at almost every meeting
people have with lots of people
joining on video, somebody
joins with their mic not muted
from a loud room, or from
a bus station or something.
And this is really disruptive.
You suddenly have somebody
with a lot of background noise
joining a meeting.
So we realized what
we needed to do
is make it really easy
to quiet that person down
and try and remove
that disruption.
So we took the time
to rework the UI
and make it much quicker to
find the controls for muting
somebody who joins a meeting.
So, as a meeting host,
you have more control
over the meeting experience.
And we think it's
small tweaks like these
that can really make for
an optimal experience
for our users.
We love working with
our trusted testers.
Like I said, it's a small group
of admins and their end users.
They're the kind of
people who we can just
e-mail out of the blue
and they'll respond to us.
They know who we are.
We work closely.
But what they
can't do is tell us
how the product is
going to work at scale.
So for that, we need
to ease ourselves
into general availability
and get broader feedback.
So we move into our
early adopter programs.
The core question is, how
does it work at scale?
By the time the product is
in the early adopter program,
it should be pretty stable.
We know that it's really hard
to deal with change management
as an admin.
So we want our admins
to know that they
can roll this product
out and it's just
going to work and support all
the use cases of their users.
They should be confident that
it will work for everybody.
They understand that we're
not going to make big changes.
And we know that if we
did make big changes,
that would be really
difficult on them.
So we announced in
the fall of 2016
that we are going
into the early adopter
program with the new Hangouts
video meeting experience.
And we've really been
focused on fit and finish.
We're now in the process
of collecting end product
feedback, tracking bugs,
and really just seeking
feedback via surveys to
see what more we need
to do to make this even better.
The next step is going to
be general availability.
We're not there yet.
But we're not going to stop
collecting feedback when
we do go to general
availability,
because it's really
important for us
to know how it's working
in the real world.
We'll keep doing-- we'll
keep checking on bugs,
we'll keep tracking
end product feedback.
But, more importantly,
we'll also
sort of kick off
that cycle again
and start thinking about what
the next product is that we
might build in this space.
And I'm going to hand
it over to Gill now
just for an example of
how this doesn't always
work out exactly as planned.
GILL WARD: Thank you, Ben.
So, of course, you couldn't
put up this great--
create this great process,
but then something
will come along that doesn't
really fit into that process.
For us, that was Jamboard.
And that's because
Jamboard isn't just
about great software.
It's about testing and producing
great hardware as well.
So, for those of you who
haven't seen Jamboard,
it's Google's take on
the digital white board.
We're trying to enable
easier team collaboration.
So if you haven't
touched Jamboard,
I believe there's one just
out in the corridor here.
Go play with it afterwards.
But you can see, you can draw,
you can write on this Jamboard.
You can insert images,
virtual stickies,
all sorts of different objects.
And you can also access
that Jamboard remotely
through other devices.
So because we're talking
about hardware here,
we had to get really
creative about the process
that we were using.
So instead of going through
trusted tester and then an EAP,
we decided to work really
closely with a few very select
partners.
We would go into the
partners' offices.
We would observe
people using Jamboard.
We'd also observe them when they
weren't using Jamboard, right?
When they were doing
brainstorming or other
collaborative work, but they
chose not to include Jamboard.
We also interviewed
users individually
to get more focused feedback
and understand how Jamboard
fit into their user journeys.
And we also
interviewed IT admins.
Because, again,
like Ben was saying,
we understand that the
IT admin is that conduit.
IT admins are
going to be the key
to the success of
deploying and managing
Jamboards out in the wild.
All right.
So we've talked about
early-stage research.
We've talked about
trusted tester--
how that's like the
first time that it
sees the customer on scale.
But it still might
change a little bit.
We've seen early
access programs, where
the product is more finalized.
And, of course, once we launch,
we don't just stop there.
Right?
Our methods of research
of gathering user feedback
just change.
We now have bigger scale.
So we use end product feedback.
We use end product
surveys, as well.
That information is
really important to us.
We have teams that will
process that feedback, that
create groupings that
categorize that feedback,
so that we can understand
both whether there
are new problems
arising, whether we fixed
the problems that we were trying
to fix, and just to understand
what's going on with our users.
And we can also look at
behavior-- actual behavior
in the product.
What are people doing?
What features are
they engaging with?
And triangulating all
these different sources
of data or feedback can help
us then prioritize the product
roadmap moving ahead.
And I do want to point out--
one of the surveys we do send
out, regularly, every quarter,
is to IT admins and developers.
Because, as we've said
multiple times already
through this
presentation, we know
that you have very
specific user journeys;
that it's critical for us
that we understand your pain
points and your needs,
so that we can ensure
that our products get rolled out
successfully to the end users.
So if you do see
this in your inbox,
please consider taking
time to fill it out.
So we've talked about the
four different stages.
I want to mention, too, being
a qualitative researcher,
that we also take into
account quantitative feedback
through all four
of these stages.
And by quantitative
feedback, I mean metrics.
And one way that
we use metrics is
by pulling together that
quantitative information
with the qualitative feedback
that we've got from our users
to make sure that we're ready
to move from one of these stages
to the next stage.
Are we ready to go from
trusted tester to EAP?
Are we ready to go
to general access?
And we want to think beyond just
click-through rates and page
views at this point, too.
And so one of the ways
that we do that at Google
is by using this framework
with a very cute acronym.
It's talking about the
range of different metrics
that we should be thinking about
when we're considering user--
or considering measuring
how our users are
interacting with our product.
There are five areas here.
I'm going to focus on just two.
And these two are
the ones that I've
seen come up again and again
as we push new products out.
So retention-- retention is
all about long-term engagement.
Does a person keep coming back?
And, for different products,
we expect different levels
of engagement over time, right?
For Gmail-- if you're
anything like me--
I'm in there
multiple times a day.
For presentations,
not quite as often.
I'm not senior enough yet.
I do a lot of other work, too.
So it's not about how often
people are coming back,
but that that number stays
pretty stable over time.
We're keeping people coming
back at a certain rate.
So for Gmail it
might be every day.
For presentations, every
week or every month.
And the Gmail example's
a little forced here,
because people-- we
know that our end users,
they have to do e-mail.
They have no choice
about the matter.
They have to be
in Gmail checking
their e-mail, for the majority
of our G Suite customers.
And so that's why we also
want to look at happiness.
So happiness is
about user opinions.
It's how happy is a user.
Often, we use satisfaction
as a measure of this.
You'll probably see that
in end product surveys--
how satisfied are you with this
product on a scale of 1 to 5,
from very happy or very
satisfied to very unsatisfied?
And we track those metrics over
time for our existing products.
We want to make sure that
they're steadily increasing.
And we also set
thresholds for those--
for new products
and new features
that we want to launch.
So HEART can tell us about
the breadth of metrics
that we're interested in using.
One principle that overrides
all of these five areas
is that our metrics should
be aligned with the goals
that we have for our user.
And by that I mean, how are we
trying to help our user achieve
their user journey?
And we also want to take
into account who that user is
as part of that, too.
So to illustrate
that in an example,
let's talk about Google Sites.
So we released a new version
of Google Sites late last year.
And one of the user goals,
as part of this release,
was that it was easier
for people to create sites
to share information.
And so, instead of just looking
at how often did somebody click
on a page that was a new
site versus an old site,
we tried to align it with
this idea of creating sites.
So one of the
metrics we looked at
was we asked people
who'd created the site--
so that was our user type--
how easy it was to do that.
And then we compared that
with how easy people reported
it was to create sites through
the old version of the product.
And another metric that was
associated with that user goal
was around retention.
The next time that person
had to create another site,
did they do so with
the new product,
or did they choose to go
back to the old product?
So we had that happiness
and retention metric.
And with those two metrics--
along with user feedback--
we felt we could
safely make a decision
to launch that product.
All right.
So, just to recap, we
have these four stages--
the early stage
testing and discovery;
releasing to our
trusted testers,
where things might
change a little bit;
then early adopter
program, where
we're releasing it more
widely, with the assumption
that things aren't going
to change too much, right?
We're just doing a little
polishing, a little fixing,
before we launch;
and then, finally,
launching to general
availability.
And, at that, I'd like to
invite Lindsay to come and talk
about Team Drive.
LINDSAY MOORE: So, to start,
can I get a show of hands--
has anyone here not
heard of Team Drives?
A couple.
So to catch you up if you're
not familiar with it--
Team Drives are new
collaborative spaces
in Google Drive.
And they live
parallel to My Drive,
but they're specifically
created with teams in mind.
And they're designed
around three core tenets.
So first-- files stay after
employees leave the company.
Second, the sharing rules are
much simpler than the sharing
rules in Drive today.
And then, lastly, they
get your team's content
all in one place.
So with Team Drives,
shared spaces
now look the same for everyone.
New members joining
a team automatically
get access to the content
they need right away.
And files don't go
missing accidentally.
So with Team Drives,
we went through each
of those phases of getting
user feedback that Ben
and Gill described as
we were progressing
towards general availability.
And through those phases,
we had three main goals.
So we needed to determine
whether Team Drives,
as a feature, was
fit for launch.
And we also needed to
understand what works well
or, maybe, what
doesn't work well,
when customers start
to use Team Drives
for their actual
day-to-day collaboration.
And then, lastly,
we really wanted
to gather longitudinal
feedback about how
domains and teams and
users within those domains
incorporate Team Drives
into their workflow.
And then, how would
they use it differently
from shared folders?
So can I get in
their show of hands--
how many of you are
from domains that
participated in our
early adopter program
for Team Drives?
Anybody?
Cool.
That's awesome.
OK.
So Early Adopter Program--
or EAP-- it was our
first, large-scale test
of Team Drives.
And, at first, was with
around 100 domains, and later,
thousands of domains.
And we were gathering
both qualitative
and quantitative
data that we could
use to evaluate our
success metrics,
and gauge our launch readiness.
And it was significant because
it represented the first time
a large amount of G Suite
admins could start testing out
Team Drives, and thinking
about how to deploy it
within their domains.
And then, also, it was
significant in that we had
to sign up customers at scale.
We were getting
feedback at scale.
We were responding to
that feedback at scale.
And that took an immense
amount of coordination
across many different
groups at Google.
So, like I said, we initially
started out our early adopter
program with just
under 100 domains.
And it was an internationally
representative group
of customers--
a range of sizes,
range of industries,
all different
types of companies.
And, as a requirement
for getting access
during this early part of
our early adopter program,
customers had to be willing
to give access to Team Drives
to at least some of
their non-IT users,
and also to have those users
participate in some feedback
surveys.
So we knew that when we
gave access to Team Drives,
we could rely on G
Suite admins to give us
their feedback as they started
trying it out and thinking
about how they were
planning on deploying it.
But we also really needed to
balance that with feedback
from end users, as well.
So, for example, we wanted to
be able to measure whether we're
hitting our success metrics
around adoption and engagement.
So, were users actually
trying Team Drives?
Did they come back to
it and try it again
after they tried
it that first time?
And we needed to understand,
was it actually addressing
the user and team
and domain level
needs that it was
intended to address?
And was it generating
satisfaction?
So, because of this,
we ran a survey
with both admins and users.
And we did that before anyone
had access to Team Drives.
And that became our
baseline for things
like satisfaction, happiness.
And then we ran another
survey after people had tried
Team Drives for a few weeks.
So that way we were able
to get a good baseline
and then use that
to evaluate success.
And through those
surveys we were also
able to get an
understanding of the whys
behind the usage metrics we saw.
So why were people
using Team Drives,
or not using Team Drives.
So thank you so much
for those of you who
participated in this early phase
of our early adopter program,
and participated in surveys,
and had your users participate
in surveys.
It's just such a valuable
source of feedback for us.
So what did we learn
from our early adopter
program for Team Drives?
Well, in addition to a
host of useful feedback,
we had two big takeaways.
And one of those was
around change management.
So we often talk about change
management at the domain level.
So, as we work
with G Suite admins
to understand what's needed
for domains to change
their processes, or
deploy new products,
features, and educate users.
But in our EAP, we heard
that teams themselves
need change management.
So with a feature
like Team Drives,
it's designed for teams.
And the whole team needs
to be coordinated and have
critical mass to actually make
a switch of that magnitude--
a switch in their processes
around where they're
storing their team's content.
So we've worked to
incorporate onboarding
into the feature that
helps teams understand
Team Drives as they get
started with using it.
The other was a
confirmation that being
able to migrate
your team's existing
content into Team Drives is
really crucial for adoption.
So today teams have their
Google Drive content
in large, shared
folder structures,
with a lot of
different file owners.
And both G Suite
admins and users
need the ability to easily
move files they don't own,
and folders full of files they
don't own, into a Team Drive.
For admins, often it's
this initial, bulk content
migration, trying
to get everything
into Team Drives
for the first time.
But, also, in larger
domains, those admins
need certain users, or
maybe even all their users,
to help them with the
scale of that task.
And then, in a lot of
companies' cultures,
you know, the teams
themselves need
to be able to move their
existing folders of content
into Team Drives as needed,
without having to involve
their G Suite admins.
So we were working to
address these findings.
And we reached out to customers
who had previously contacted us
with feedback about that very
thing, about content migration.
We needed to make sure we were
going to get the experience
right for admins and users
across different kinds
of domains, different
expectations around access
or sharing or the
need for control.
So, really, the ability to
reach back out to customers
like this is an important
part of what makes
trusted tester and early
adopter program so powerful.
We're really trying to create
a relationship-- cultivate
that relationship--
where we are able to have
a back-and-forth conversation
about our products
and features.
So one of this customers
that we reached out to
was Hingham Institution for
Savings, which is a community
bank in the Boston area.
So I will now bring
Joe Bears, who
is the CIO at
Hingham up on stage,
and we'll hear
from him about what
it was like to participate
in giving feedback to Google.
JOSEPH BEARS: Hi, everyone.
LINDSAY MOORE:
[INAUDIBLE] great.
So we understand that you guys
are trying to transition more
fully into the cloud.
And moving to G Suite
is a part of that.
So tell us why that's
important for Hingham.
JOSEPH BEARS: For
multiple reasons.
Server consolidation being one
of them, and disaster recovery.
With G Suite, we've
been able to get out
of the business of
maintaining servers.
We've cut down about a
third of our servers.
And we're not doing
things like backup on them
anymore, doing anti-virus
updates, things of that nature.
Instead, we're able
to take more time,
you know, advancing
the company goals,
doing things that
help our customers.
LINDSAY MOORE: So why Drive?
How is Drive an
important piece of that?
JOSEPH BEARS:
Drive's brought a lot
of sharing and collaboration.
Previously, with our old
productivity suite, we were--
somebody would go in.
We'd have a group of people
that needed to update something.
And they'd go in,
try to update it,
and they'd tell them that
it was a read-only copy.
That would result
in users ending up
having to make a copy.
And then, we'd all--
somebody would have to come
along and roll back all
those changes into one copy.
With Google Now, we're able to--
everybody can work
on it the same time.
So there's a lot
more collaboration.
And it saves a lot
of efficiencies.
LINDSAY MOORE: So
why did you guys
want to be part of
the early adopter
program for Team Drives?
JOSEPH BEARS: Initially,
when we set up the--
when we got into
Drive, we needed
to have a common area just
to share all the data.
And what we did
there was we created
what I call a service account.
And with that service account we
replicated our folder structure
into it.
And then, from there,
we shared all that out.
When we saw Team
Drives come along,
we knew that it looked
like what we were actually
trying to accomplish.
LINDSAY MOORE: Yeah.
So it sounds like that that
wasn't optimal for management.
And that Team Drives was more
like what you were looking for.
JOSEPH BEARS: Yeah,
it was exactly what
we were looking for.
LINDSAY MOORE: So what
did you do when you first
got access to Team Drives?
JOSEPH BEARS: We
started by setting it up
in one of our back offices.
And we ran with that for
approximately a month, two
months.
And, from there, we started
spreading out and moving it
to different departments.
It really rolled out quite easy.
From there, we even had some
of our branches even set
up their own Team Drives and
migrated the data on their own.
So it worked really well.
LINDSAY MOORE: So
speaking of users,
how did you introduce
Team Drives to them?
Like how did you orient people
to just a totally new file
sharing system?
JOSEPH BEARS: It's been a
pretty smooth transition.
We started by replicating the
whole folder structure that
was on our old servers.
And from there, we--
sorry.
Lost my-- you know, from there,
we rolled it out to everybody.
And working through
a web browser really
didn't turn out to be
that much of a difference
in working through
File Explorer.
So it really wasn't
a huge change.
LINDSAY MOORE: Great.
So how have people have been
using Team Drive so far?
JOSEPH BEARS: The
best way to explain it
is sharing and collaboration.
Like I said, everybody's able
to do work a lot smoother
and a lot more efficiently.
So it's really worked
out well in that sense.
LINDSAY MOORE: And do
you have any specific use
cases for a team at Hingham
that you can share with us?
JOSEPH BEARS: Probably our
human resources department,
the onboarding process.
It used to be a process where
the human resources would
send e-mails around, and then
attach like the onboarding
form.
And now, with Team
Drives, they're
just setting it up within
the Team Drive folders.
And then they send out a
notification via Team Drives
that everybody just goes in and
works on it as they need be.
And it's a process that
was getting held up before.
And it's no longer
getting held up.
It's great.
LINDSAY MOORE: That's
so good to hear.
So, like I mentioned
earlier, Hingham
had ended up participating
in this follow-up
study we did, at some point
during our early adopter
program, about
content migration.
So why did you guys want to
participate again in that?
JOSEPH BEARS: Well, we
wanted to have input.
Like I said, we had that user--
the utility user, as I call it--
set up, that we have data in.
And we wanted to have input
on how to get that data out
of the utility user
and move it over
into the Team Drive folders.
Additionally, we're
changing as a company.
And we want to have
more partners that
are open to feedback.
We have other partners
that we give feedback to,
and they're not
great at responding.
To contrast that, we
actually have one partner
that's involved in doing
a licensing audit with us,
and it's not really helping
to advance the company's goal.
It's more like a sales tactic.
So it's great to have Google.
And they're listening
to our feedback.
And we see it show up very
quickly in the products.
LINDSAY MOORE: Great.
For your users
themselves, what do they
get out of participating
in something like this?
JOSEPH BEARS: A lot of our
users actually commented to me
that they enjoyed doing the--
they enjoyed the whole
process of giving feedback.
And some of them actually
said they learned more
about the product
in the process.
So that was a
really great thing.
LINDSAY MOORE: Cool.
So when you participate in
an early adopter program,
like you did, it's not a
finished product, right?
So how does that impact you?
Like, what are your
thoughts on using products
that aren't fully finished?
JOSEPH BEARS: We don't mind.
We realize that that's
something that's
going to occur with a
new product like that.
And we've made a
decision as a company
that we want to be more on
the leading edge of technology
like that, instead of the
trailing edge, where stuff
is more fully fleshed out.
But, you know, it
works great for us.
LINDSAY MOORE: So
just to wrap up--
what does it mean for an
organization like Hingham
to be involved in this
feedback process with Google?
JOSEPH BEARS: It
means a lot to us.
It's great that a
small company like ours
can have feedback into a
product that Google's creating.
We have another data center
that we're constantly
trying to give feedback to,
and they don't really listen.
They ask for the
feedback and we never
see it get into the product.
So it's great to
see it, you know,
see the changes that we ask
for end up in a product.
LINDSAY MOORE: Well,
thank you so much, Joe,
for coming here and speaking
with us today, and sharing
Hingham's experience with
the Team Drives early adopter
program.
We really appreciate it.
And then, for those
of you in the audience
who were part of that
early adopter program
as well-- thank you so
much for being part of it,
taking the time to share
your feedback with us.
JOSEPH BEARS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LINDSAY MOORE: So what does
it mean to test products
like a Googler?
It means we are always looking
for feedback on our products,
no matter what stage of the
development cycle we're in.
And we're always looking for
new ways to engage our customers
and pull in their
valued feedback.
We're really just
in constant motion
through this research cycle
with each of our products.
And in order for us to get
this valuable user feedback,
it's really vital that we
have partners to work with.
So without their help-- which
is, essentially, your help--
this would be much harder.
So if you are interested,
like Gill said earlier,
in having your company join
our G Suite user panel,
so we can include your end users
in our early iterative studies,
for example--
follow this link up
here on the left.
So you can sign up
and express interest.
And then, for any of
you in the audience who
are IT professionals
or developers,
you can also sign
up using the link
on the right to help product
development on Google Cloud
Platform.
So, in either case, it's like
a quick little five-minute
survey.
You'll get your name
in our database.
And we can't promise we'll
be able to include everyone
in our panels.
But we're really
continually looking
for more participants
for our studies.
And we really look forward
to getting your feedback,
so we can continue to drive
product excellence within G
Suite.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]